hey everyone welcome to live coding with
Jessie I'm Jessie and today we're gonna
migrate some more data so a little while
ago we had a similar stream so the plan
is I have a spreadsheet on each row in
the spreadsheet represents a piece of
data that we would like to migrate from
a sequel server database to a my sequel
database and to get from one database to
the other we're using two tools to help
us out a little node script so nodejs is
it's a way to run JavaScript server-side
and then we're also using the WordPress
REST API to get the data the rest of the
way so node pulls the data out of the
sequel server database and then the
WordPress API puts the data into the my
sequel database I might mess that up
so a sequel server to my sequel but
that's the plan I'm gonna win you ahead
of time it's not the most exciting thing
in the world but I think it's a an OK
example of some things that may have to
happen when you're migrating from an old
system to a new system and you can't
just write one script and have
everything come over it just doesn't
work like that all the time so we're
gonna have to kind of pick through the
data try to bring it over and in as big
a chunks as we possibly can but we still
need to bring it over in a way that
we're gonna be able to make sense of it
all and use it so we're gonna switch
back and forth between the the data
table we're gonna modify our node script
and run it and then we're also gonna
check on this is a website that we're
altima t building here so we're gonna
check on the old version of the website
to try to figure out like is this data
live do we need it and if it's still
there in the website like what's the
context of this data to give us a better
idea of where we should put it in the
new database that's the plan my wife is
messaging me on my other screen and
she's doing some coding she's doing the
Udacity front-end enter degree so she's
message she's sending me screenshots of
her code and messaging me she must not
know I'm streaming all right so let me
switch over to my screen here you can
see this is what I was working on right
before I started I mean just this okay
I'm going to check the live chat and
then we'll get started
hey everyone all right cool looks like
you're talking about a race that
happened this weekend Oh Matthew asked
if she started the memory project yet
she's on the memory project right now
that's the one she's working on so she's
working on some some click handlers for
the cards and that was it actually works
for her in code pen but not locally on
her machine so anyway I think she'll
probably be able to figure it out and
she's been doing a pretty good job of
getting getting through it okay so I
brought over here let me start my
Pomodoro session I'm going to do 25
minutes of code
in this case data migration and then
five minutes a question answer and we're
gonna go back and forth I do have a
meeting in less than an hour and a half
now so if we get a ton of questions I
may not be able to answer them all but
we're well within our normal time range
here of around an hour for a stream
someone asks for the website for this
palma two hour timer so I'm going to
copy and paste it into the chat here if
you click it and it doesn't work then
please try copying and pasting it
alright so I found some data here's the
data that I found here this is really
small I kind of need to keep it small to
be able to see the range but I'm I'm
just gonna explain a little bit about
what's going on here I found some data
here that has to do with residents life
so like the dorm rooms on campus where
students live and things like that so I
assume you know this may be able to be
like its own section its own post type
in the in the WordPress and in the
database or maybe we can just tag it in
with with something else but I need to
know what category this goes in so
that's why I just searched for it here
and I could see hey this is Residence
Life so let's click it and see all right
what section does this fall under so it
actually looks like this is kind of its
own section it's like a top level here
so it's dot edu slash Residence Life so
it we may be able to put this in its own
section just want to see if we have it
if it's even a kind of a top level link
here so I'm not sure where it's linked
from
I'm guessing it would be student life
where it's linked from so I'm clicking
in here if you know I might be able to
put it under the student life like in
the section with all that data that we
brought over Residence Life does that
guy take us to the same spot oh it does
it does interesting maybe we'll do that
then this would be a little bit easier
than making a completely new new post
site so what we'll do is we already have
a section for stuff like this under
Student Life and let me let me pull up
the wordpress did I make this yeah I
think this is it all right so we have a
WordPress installation we've been
putting all this data into and we can
see I will make this a bit bigger fuel
to see so we have all these different
data types to keep things straight for
us here and we need to find the one that
student life now the users who are going
to be in charge of editing this very few
users are going to see all of this it's
it's a bit much right so most people
only see maybe one or two types so it'll
be much cleaner easier to edit I thought
I had student life stuff student profile
pages oh yeah
student life pages there we are okay so
we already have a bunch of student life
pages and while we have quite a few if
three pages of student life pages looks
like these are a lot of the student
organizations okay wonderful
I think this will fit well in there so
here's what we need to do we need a few
pieces of information in order to make
this script work so we need to know what
the folder ID is that this data lives in
and we also need to know
what the post type the slug is right for
so it's like a unique identifier for
that post site in this case it's gonna
be a student life page I believe it will
be student life pages I think that's it
we'll find out if I run it and it
doesn't work then I'll know that's the
wrong one and we need this ID is 486 so
let's plug in 486 we're gonna save that
quickly I'll just go over this basically
we're using the sequel eyes - all right
this doesn't we're all importing this
stuff right so this doesn't come with
nodejs by default right so we're using
sequel eyes to help us interact with a
sequel database a little bit easier
right and then we have our our sequel
query if it's a little bit different
than you're used to
sequel is kind of different flavors
depending on the type of sequel database
so a query for my sequel may look
slightly different than sequel server
but you can kind of figure out what's
going on if you are familiar with sequel
basically we're just getting a little
bit of we're specifying what data we
want from from where we want it so from
what section of the database we want it
and this data length greater than 0 just
means I don't even want to bother
pulling in any data that is empty right
it doesn't have any content at all right
and in our case our contents HTML markup
if it doesn't have markup I don't really
want it and that's pretty much it then
down here we're basically taking that
data we're getting and we are creating
posts in WordPress and then having them
put into my sequel database and we're
taking the the data that has a certain
name and my sequel database and we're
giving it a name
that is more appropriate or I'm sorry in
our sequel server database we're giving
it a name that's more appropriate for
WordPress and my sequel and fact I do
want to get rid of this that was for a
previous thing we're working on alright
great that that looks
oops actually need a key that looks
perfect
let's not run this so we need to run my
good Jess alright it's doing something
and let's stop that and we're gonna
check to make sure that these got
inserted so right now we have 50 items
if i refresh and it's more than 50 then
it works nope it didn't work alright so
why did it not work probably because I
put in the wrong post type so student
like pages what did I put in wrong
all right let's check what the post type
is you know it actually may tell it may
tell me you're in this look
student life pages mmm that looks right
so what did I do
STD ent pages oh you know what I don't
think it's plural and it needs to be
singular student life page right because
each one of these is a posts I'm
creating a new student life page that's
that's the problem all right now let's
check there we go now we have 67 items
so women from fifty to sixty seven
that's our extra 17 items that we just
added and so here we go these this it's
it's supposed to be short for Assisi
Heights so definitely gonna change that
title before it shows up in any one
search but that's that's basically the
process that we go through now I can go
in here I have all these selected and
I'm gonna remove it from the table don't
worry though I have a copy of this this
spreadsheet in case accident remove
stuff that I shouldn't but for this one
trying to get rid of everything as soon
as we pull it over and that way just
visually it'll be very easy for me to
see the progress and the rows go down
and down and down okay
I do I see a few questions in the chat
so if any of you are new please be
patient well I have a timer on right now
when the timer goes off then I will go
back to the chat and answer your
questions okay here we we have some more
things here I'm gonna try to find
something that doesn't require me to
create a custom post type let's see
these look like people lots of people
and they don't work here
are they alumni are they speakers yeah I
don't think I think these may have been
speakers distinguished speakers serious
okay
I'm not sure where I want to put that
right now and I know you probably can't
see how small this is it so I'm trying
to read it out a bit I can delete this
some of these are just tiny okay there's
just such tiny fragments of pieces of
data we just don't need them let's see
okay these look like residence halls
Residence Life staff okay is this what
contact information or just general
information I saw I think this can go in
the same spot
that we wanted in let's just verify and
see here do we have information about
residence halls here Residence Life
residence halls yep so that's where
these are each one of these residence
halls will have its own page and some
info and I believe that's where this is
coming from residence halls
okay great yes so let's take this and
grab this data and since we're gonna
send it to the same place all we need to
do is change that folder ID so this will
be 537 let's go up in here five three
seven we'll save it nothing else needs
to change and we'll run this again
twenty open the more I can get in per
query the better once I did a query and
we got like I don't know around 500 at
once and that was that was awesome I
think that was the biggest one that I've
done so far all right great so we have
those we shouldn't I know this will work
but it's always good to verify not great
to just you know get ahead of it yep now
we're up to 87 items wonderful and so
now we can remove these let's see yeah
we can remove these from here I am I was
not employed here at this university
whenever the old site was built so I'm
learning
so much about the website now as I go
through and I get all this content there
are like whole sections that I didn't
even know existed let's see it looks
like these are some more these are more
information these guys use these are
just image galleries I'm gonna bring
these over I'm not exactly sure we'll
keep them I know some of the older
images aren't great quality so we may
want to replace them but better just to
bring it over and this is 3/5 39 is the
section 513 so let's just change that
over here 537 about 5:30 5:30 it looks
like 536 could come over - I think I'll
bring over 536 as well so let's do 539
save that run it and I'll do 536 as well
say that run it wonderful will verify
ninety seven items great now we can just
delete all of this wonderful okay so
this is the pattern this is what I do
when I'm on campus so usually I'm on
campus two days a week in my office my
pattern of working for the last few
weeks has been try to squeeze in all my
meetings into those two days a week so
that takes up a lot of my time and then
when I'm not doing that we're taking
care of like other tasks like paperwork
and things that I usually only do in the
office
I'm doing this over and over again so
I'm almost through I'm getting pretty
happy about that so it probably doesn't
really make for a great live stream to
do this I'll you know I don't know maybe
you get just kind of an appreciation for
a way that you could handle something
like this but I'll do what i'ma do
alright so all this for a few more
minutes and then I'll see what kind of
questions we have and then we'll go from
there
and you all let me know if you really
want to see any more of this you'd
rather me guy kind of go to questions
keep it a shorter stream
I would love I'd like right now to find
some more student life things and just
try to like chunk it together so we
don't have to change every you know both
pieces of data but I'm also not gonna
spend a bunch of time scrolling through
here to try to find some data so let's
see we have baccalaureate 2015 image
gallery I don't think we need that these
are old 2015 and 2017 2015 so it looks
like we have some things in here that we
just we don't need to bring over these
are all old so let's get rid of them
this is 2016 2016 2014 actually let me
yeah these are all together here for
sure commence mansion
yeah let's get rid of that commencement
information yeah I don't need that
because that's whoops there you go yeah
let's delete that these conferences I'm
not sure if they if they want these
conferences like the details from past
conferences or not maybe I'll just leave
them for now and I'll ask my boss about
it
okay these all right so recognize some
of these names as people that work here
okay I don't really want to try to sort
out where all these people work and get
them in the right spots so let's just
keep on going
Oh conspiracy theories that sounds like
a cool course that's crazy that's
actually a course
let me see it's possible that these
courses what happened I lost it it's
possible that those courses might be old
and we can get rid of him oh you know
what these are a bunch of old events
as well I don't know if the theater
department would want to keep some old
events just for students prospective
students to see so maybe we'll I'll ask
about this as well let's see
it looks like I can remove some of these
too this makes me happy when I can just
get rid of stuff this we're not gonna
bring it over let's see yeah all of
these looks like they are listings for
events that have happened at least a
year ago get rid of it all it's I'm sure
it doesn't matter to you and it seems
boring but I feels amazing when I could
just get rid of those because that means
I don't even I don't have to do anything
I don't have to create post types I
don't have to migrate the data like just
like hey it's it's done okay great you
know maybe I might make this just a bit
bigger because I know it's gonna be hard
for you all to see and it's most
definitely a hum difficult for me to see
let's see if I can just make this bigger
in bulk come on let's get a 16 yeah
that's so much bigger and let me get a
font that I like better you know a we
used Roboto for everything we may as
well use it for our spreadsheets right
okay cool
a little bit better I can still see all
the data that I need so this is fun so
our academic organizations student clubs
pilgrimage this is for 69 looks like
this could also go
in that student life so let's let's pull
that in four six nine
so for sixty nine we're gonna save that
run it and verify so we're gonna from
ninety seven it should say ninety nine
yep
ninety nine awesome and this isn't the
end of it like after I would do this I
would then have to go in and make sure
like are the titles okay you know a lot
of the titles contain abbreviations and
things that nobody's going to understand
so I got to clean up the titles got to
make sure the slugs for the post types
are something that we can actually work
with and fit nicely in a URL
sometimes one there'll be multiple posts
and really we could condense it down
into one so there's a lot of cleanup
that happens as well afterwards this is
just kind of the first step and let's
see
alright counseling looks like we got a
nice chunk of data here for counseling
health center alright let's do that I do
you know what I want to see counselling
service I want to see what part of the
website this is on so let's check the
website again I gotta go to the search
he's I can never remember how to spell
count cou NSEL counselling service I
just I don't want to get the wrong info
because we have a counseling program
where we teach people about counseling
but also counseling services there we go
Wellness Center my mother-in-law is
actually a counselor here at the same
university as I am counseling service is
under Wellness Center okay and I bet the
Wellness Center pages are under student
life let's see health services
counseling services yep it's under
Student Life so let's throw it let's
throw it in there with Student Life 481
is what we want for 81 and that's
migrated down the road if we ever you
know end up seeing like wow this this
post site has way too many posts and it
is huge we can always break it out and
into separate ones but right we don't
want to optimize too much early right
it's it can be a you know kind of a
waste of time to do it too early and it
may not even be necessary at all you
know ever so we want to try to avoid
that if we can so let's double check
we'll verify and my timer is almost up
so we'll do some question and answer
here in just a few seconds alright
awesome so that works and the last thing
we want to do before we forget is remove
all of these posts that were in that
folder with the idea 480
delete great okay so I'm gonna set a
five-minute timer but I'm not sure I'm
gonna go back and do another Pomodoro
session of just data migration you all
let me know like how valuable this is to
you I kind of I have to do this it's
getting down like I can't put this off
any longer I gotta get the rest of the
data in so I really need to make sure I
get this done otherwise I would probably
be streaming me doing something else
maybe a little bit more fun so if you
have a question please put it in the
live chat now I just want to mention
everyone I'm gonna go to the revolution
conference in Virginia Beach later this
week
so I'll stream probably tomorrow if I
can but then I likely would not be able
to stream the rest of the week so
Wednesday Thursday Friday no streams if
for some reason like maybe I can find
some really good internet when I'm there
then maybe I can do a stream but I I
don't know beforehand so I can't really
guarantee anything if anybody is in the
Virginia Beach area and is either going
to the conference that you know come
come find me let me know that'd be
awesome or if you're just in the area
even if you're not going to the
conference if you if you'd like to hang
out or something let me know all right
so I started starting right at the top
of the live chat I'm just going to
scroll down try to answer the questions
as they came in Phoenix says hey how's
it going Phoenix good to see you
Ezekiel says everyone something is going
on with me okay
Ezekiel what's up what's going on all
right Theresa says thanks was a Theresa
that us
yeah all right to recess for the website
though is it Theresa am i pronouncing
that right if not please let me know
but anyway anyway true so you're welcome
Abdul Aziz is here how's it going thanks
for watching
hmmm e says hi how's it going not bad no
I'm I'm starting to get a little nervous
and like like I don't know nervous /
excited about launching the site so
that's how it's going for me how you
doing hey and it's here hey Anna how's
it going Chris asks if I've tried out
CSS grid yet I've done really minimal
work with CSS grid so I don't honestly
at this point my nose if CSS grade is so
little like I don't even want to try to
explain anything about it to anyone yet
because I would probably mess it up but
it's something I really do want to learn
more about there's so many tutorials and
things that I'd like to do right now I
just like since it's getting close to
launch time for this site everything is
focused on that so I haven't even been
like doing my usual I usually try to
learn new things as I'm working like
even if it's just a half hour a day but
I've even cut that out
so hopefully afterwards after it
launches on June 4th hopefully I'll have
a little bit more time for learning
Christian says Jessie it is nice to see
the real work you do also
alright cool yeah I mean pretty much
everything that stream is I mean it is
things that I'm doing but I try to save
the things that I think will be most
exciting or like informative they are
helpful for you all so but I guess
there's value in showing kind of like
the tedious boring stuff sometimes -
John's here haha he says hail of the
finer repetitive details the doing is
not so pretty the end product is the gem
yeah I hope us what's what DC says good
luck for that I guess you're talking
about my trip so thanks Austin says I
live in Virginia Beach come use my
internet oh how awesome awesome Austin
like if if you want I mean I you don't
have to let me use your internet but if
you're gonna be in Virginia Beach if
you're interested in trying like meeting
up getting a coffee or something at some
point let me know you can I think my
link to my Twitter is in the description
you can DM me if you want or whatever
you know so that that might be kind of
cool if we could find a coffee shop that
has decent Wi-Fi might be able to do a
little stream or something I don't know
sometimes coffee shops aren't great for
a stream if there's a lot of people the
background noise is insane but anyway I
I'm down to hang out I don't know how
much time I'll have cause it would be
conference stuff all the time but I'll I
would try to work it out all right we
have greetings from Ukraine and you know
let me grab that's in Cyrillic but I'm
gonna use Google Translate to figure out
what that is
I then okay so Ivan says greetings from
Ukraine
greetings Ivan thank you and thanks for
watching
in it says any news I guess if I'm
assuming you were here when I talked
about the conference I'm going to so I
won't repeat that but other than that I
think any news
not really I mentioned before I've been
on a diet and I've been trying to
exercise and that's going well I'm
continuing to lose weight so I'm happy
about that I have a lot more energy
yeah so that's that's pretty good
all right how many says I'm doing fine
thanks have started learning es6 or is
it still early I'm not I'm not here are
you asking me if I started learning es6
or if you should start learning es6 I
guess I can answer both so I do know
quite a bit of es6 I don't I don't
really use all of us six all the time so
I you forget what you don't use right
but you know there are some parts of
year six that I use like every day like
arrow functions Oh Mme says both of us
okay cool yeah like I mean even
especially we were doing react like we
were using arrow functions all the time
I believe like map filter sort those
things I think are yes six template
literals love template literal syntax
use that a lot let haunts those are es6
so yes I mean there is a good chunk of
es6 that you know I use all the time but
there are certainly some things that you
know we don't use really what else
object D structuring so I mean there's
there thing I think it's getting to the
point now where people could potentially
be using es6 and not even realize that
it's es6 because it's just getting so
kind of blended in with what people are
doing tutorials are using it so which is
good right I mean we're already on ES
eight es6 been around for a while like I
I think it will start to get even more
and more like normal browser support a
lot of it now so anyway I I love all the
parts of es6 that I use frequently it
just there's just very helpful if you're
not sure what yes six is it's also
called es2015
they are some new features that were
added to the javascript language way
back in
like 2015 I don't know exactly when they
were added but around there and you know
with with transpilers you know people
started using them before that you were
even official so anyway that's what we
talk about when we're saying yes es6 and
years 2015 so if you want to know what
those what exactly was added you know
try searching es6 I should be able to
find something probably on that first
page of results that'll go through it
let's see Phoenix says hey Jesse just
wanted to ask what average salary can a
guy in India expect for remote work in
u.s. let's consider a full-time
front-end developer job all right well
that's it's going to be a little bit
hard for me to answer that because you
know certainly I would think like a
companies here in the United States when
they look at how to to compensate a
remote worker what they usually do at
least here in the United States is they
say okay what is a fair wage for where
that person lives so for instance in the
United States in San Francisco cost of
living is really really high like
amazingly high it's just astounding to
me how much you know for instance like
houses cost out there so let's just say
I'm just kind of making these numbers up
let's just say the average front-end
developer in San Francisco makes
$150,000 a year if I were to get a job
with a company but stay where I'm at and
work remotely even if the companies
headquartered in San Francisco they're
gonna look at my market and they're
gonna say wow that's a really
economically depressed area you can make
a living of you know much left excuse me
much it takes much less to you know
raise a family and get a house and
everything where I'm at so they may say
like okay we're gonna pay you $80,000 a
year so you got to take that into
consideration so I don't know what they
would do they might take into account
your stand
living I would imagine you could
probably end up getting a little bit
more you know a company I think that's
headquartered in an expensive area is
still most likely going to be a bit more
willing to pay more because they're used
to paying more for you know their
employees where they're at but in terms
of giving a number I don't really know I
know like in in Pittsburgh the closest
big city to me is Pittsburgh and I know
in Pittsburgh for like a front-end full
sack engineer you're looking at like
minimum basically like I would never
take a job for less than like seventy
five thousand a year in Pittsburgh
anything below that it's kind of like I
just wonder if the company is really
willing to put forth resources to make a
good product if that's what they're
willing they either one like have no
idea what developers are worth or which
is bad or two they they don't care
enough or don't have enough money to
really put into a project to make it
succeed so either way I don't really
wanna be working there so I my bare
minimum would be like seventy five
thousand a year and then I would
consider something like in the 90s would
be a good offer you know so anything
over ninety thousand would what I would
consider to be a really good offer and
so that kind of the mid-range would be
between 75 and 90 and that's US dollars
per year and if we're talking
so--that's Pittsburgh if we're talking
San Francisco I don't know add like
thirty thousand on to those figures
uh-huh because it's it's much more
expensive okay New York's pretty
expensive San Francisco as far as I know
is the most expensive place in the u.s.
New York's also up there
as being pretty expensive as well
zoo zoo hyb I'm not sure how to
pronounce that please correct me if I'm
pronouncing it wrong but anyway they say
hey I'm learning I'm new to learning
node I want to show data from the
console to webpage using body parser but
I can't hmm
all right so let me check my time see
how I can answer this truth I'm not sure
right off the bat with the answer the
only time I use body parser is when I'm
grabbing data from an HTML form and I
want to do things with that data in node
so I've never dealt with that specific
use case trying to certainly get some
resource I could maybe point you to I'm
not sure if anybody in here has worked
with something similar a node please let
us know in the live chat otherwise I'm
gonna try to keep thinking of it if I
could think of something before the
streamed over I would definitely mention
it but like I said I haven't dealt with
that specific situation so I'm not
exactly sure
okay how many says I'm doing a course on
udemy that focuses a lot on es6
okay so that was while the you had the
question with the es6 it says it's
called mobile web specialists and
focuses also on service workers all
right cool service workers are amazing
we're working with service workers in
this project as well but a lot of it is
set up behind the scenes already bye bye
next j/s which we're using so we don't
have to directly deal with them but it
it a service worker can sit between the
client and the server and intercept
network data and
do things with it so if it essentially
it could cache data and then the client
clients Network call goes out like
normal but it doesn't go any further
because the service work will say oh
they want this data we already have a
cache just send it back and then you
have like zero second load times because
the data is right there because the
service worker actually lives in the
browser all right so it doesn't have to
go anywhere it doesn't even have to
leave the browser so really cool really
cool things you can also do things like
calculations that would normally crush
your performance like in the Dom you
know scrolling and if you make
everything all janky you could offload
it to a serviceworker do all the
calculations there and not mess up you
know your flow basically it wouldn't
render block at all it wouldn't block
the normal stuff that needs to happen on
the page so that would that'd be pretty
cool if you were gonna do like I don't
like image processing somebody uploads
an image you want to do some really like
intense intent resource intensive things
to it handle that in the serviceworker
and then the user can still scroll
around your page while that's doing its
thing I'll get nikki says es6 is the
language itself not meaning JavaScript
it's in the official spec when learning
JavaScript you also learn yes 6.now
automatically unless you're learning old
material okay that's that's pretty cool
I didn't even think about that but yeah
I mean when I went through the basic
tutorials of JavaScript
es6 was still well early on it wasn't
out yet and then later on it was still
really kind of new so you didn't it just
wasn't there but that's cool that it's a
part of the tutorials now I mean that's
I think as it should be right because
there are some things that were a lot
harder to do before es6 and I I don't
see that much value in making a new you
know learner
do it the harder way when you know not
even the advanced people don't like that
anymore
so yeah I think that's good that they're
teaching it like that Ivan says ask if
I'm using something else other than
react in the front end or if I yeah I
mean well I've been using react for most
of the projects it's it's not that I
have anything against the other stuff
it's just I'm kind of taking the
approach right now that I'd rather get
really good at one thing then try to
know a little bit about all the things
so I have to give up on some things that
I think are really cool but it's it's
for the sake of trying to make
ultimately a better product so I've
chosen react and so for the time being
I'm pretty much just building things and
react and if I'm not using react that
means it's simple enough that I can just
build it with just plain JavaScript yeah
so that's what I'm at right now
we do have some other videos on the free
code camp channel using things like view
and angular so you could check the
backlog of videos and and see some other
things as well so we're not we're not
like just just react but for me
personally I'm using a lot of react
I've been asked if I'm the creator free
code camp No so Quincy I don't know I
don't know if you all know Quincy so
Quincy created free code camp he is the
founder and he is the I don't know what
its title president
I'm not let me look him up on Twitter to
see what his title is cuz I'm not sure
Quincy's so humble his Twitter says
teacher at free code camp he's in charge
of it all so anyway Quincy Larson is who
you want so if you want to follow him on
Twitter it's at Ostia
OSs
a anyway he's very very awesome guy so
yeah he's the one that started I my
involvement with free code camp is
pretty limited to these live streams on
YouTube I've talked with some of the
other people from free code camp and had
some like video chats and things but
there are a ton of other people that
work on various areas of free code camp
so there's a lot of people behind the
scenes that nobody even knows about that
they're making this happen and working
for free - I mean almost all the stuff
that gets done on free code campus is
from fallen to your time
Edie
edek son to e EDI CSO n says hi bet I'm
28 am I too old to be a programmer what
do you think no definitely not too old
not so you're never too old to be a
programmer I've seen stories of people a
lot older switching careers learning how
to become a programmer and get having
successful programming careers so I am
32 years old I taught high school for a
little while in my mid-20s and then I
switched into programming in my late 20s
so I had I learned a little bit before
that but I really kind of got serious
about it switched into it late 20s I'm
employed now as a full-time front-end
developer I don't know how successful
you would consider me but I make enough
money to support my family and pay my
bills so I mean I have four kids of a
wife so I'd say that's you know it's
pretty successful right I mean I'm not
not making millions or anything but
certainly can support myself and my
family
so yeah 28 definitely not too old Mert
says hi says I love free code camp
awesome
awesome thank you I love it too that's
why I do this stuff so I mean I do have
my own YouTube channel I do some videos
on there but as you all know like the
the majority of my hours spent doing
YouTube suffer are spent with free code
camp it's I think it's some special
honey it helps people evidence says I
studied three years in my country but
then I came to us and I had been working
as a barber I love these two professions
Oh
oh cool I have a lot of family members
that are our barbers and hairdressers
actually so I've got one uncle two great
uncles and two cousins first cousins
that are all barbers or and or
hairdressers so definitely appreciate
what it takes to do that job it's
Francis says have you tried PHP what can
you say about it
I have tried PHP and for this project in
particular I've done a little PHP so all
those custom post types you saw in in
WordPress I created a plug-in in PHP
that creates those and some custom
taxonomies as well so I I don't have a
lot to say about PHP I can do a little
bit when I need to in PHP it's not my
preferred language but I mean like any
language I think whatever language you
work with the most is usually the one
you're most comfortable with
so I'm not that comfortable with it
because I don't do that much and I think
you know from most languages can do most
things right most your major languages
so it seems like the strengths and
weaknesses of those languages are mostly
felt kind of at the extremes where like
you really need performance and then you
could start to see some differences but
for most things I think you know PHP is
is as good as you know it was good as
anything else for me personally if I was
getting into web development which I am
in it now but if I was trying to pick
and I was a beginner and trying to pick
what to learn I personally would go with
full sack JavaScript because my view on
it is you only have so many you know
hours in the day to learn why not learn
one language and be able to do two
things with it right
running in back and then learned two
different languages and since you got a
no JavaScript for web development anyway
why not just stick with it so and that's
nothing against PHP it's just kind of a
being really practical about it and
trying to be as efficient as possible
with my learning but if you do want to
work with anything like WordPress which
a ton of websites run on WordPress so
there's definitely a market there then
you're probably gonna want to know PHP
cuz that's what it's built on also if
you want to work on Drupal or Joomla
which are not as popular as WordPress
but you still see them a lot those also
run off PHP so it's definitely still
valuable to learn let's see Lawrence
says do you know scratch and is it good
oh yeah scratch for those of you who
don't know the scratches it's like a
visual programming language I believe it
was developed at MIT mainly to help
teach kids programming so you have these
tiny little colored blocks that
represent different actions you can take
in code so you have one for like a for
loop you have ones that represent
variables like iterators you know
different basic things while loops and
you just click and drag the blocks over
to where your code lives and so you
build the code like that instead of
typing it out you click and drag these
different colors so it's it's kind of
easier for kids with little fingers you
know and not quite don't really have the
dexterity yet for a lot of typing or the
spelling skills really can still make
some cool things in scratch and there
have been some people to do some pretty
advanced things in scratch like usually
games and things so it's I mean I
wouldn't do like a real project in
scratch for a client or anything it's
not a programming language like that but
it's it's just another layer of
action geared towards making programming
easier for for children so if you're
just starting out starting with scratch
is not a bad idea even if you're older I
know
Harvard's computer science 50 course
start you out in scratch the first
assignment for that course is scratch
and that course is geared towards people
who are 18 19 20 like around that age
range so scratch is just a cool place to
start to get an understanding of water
loops what are if statements and things
like that without having to get having
to get bogged down by all this syntax
right so definitely awesome for kids but
also awesome for adults who are just
starting out in programming and it's
just kind of fun it's like if you just
want to mess around and do something
scratch is fun
how many says it's really good to see
these people with different cultures
gathered together by enthusiasm for
coding yeah definitely definitely i know
i'm i've talked about this before i'm
sure but i think i think that there's
really something special going on here
with free code camp and with these live
streams in that like there's there's a
community that's grown so like not
everybody attends every live stream and
that's fine because everybody has their
own lives and priorities and i you know
that's that's totally fine but like you
know in general there's quite there are
quite a few people who are regulars you
know who you see you know from time to
time in here that start to know each
other that even start to work on
projects together
outside of this live stream that help
each other out and that's awesome you
know people have come in to the chat and
watch the streams and just been learning
and then they've gone on interviews and
then they've gotten job offers and
started working and have kind of checked
in throughout this whole process and
updated us in in the chat so i think
that's cool people have shared like i i
know i share a lot of my struggles with
with mental health and you know even
physical health and things and I know
some of you is shared as well so I and I
know there are people from everywhere a
lot of different countries different
cultures different religions different
you know everything that you can be
that's different from each other I think
we've seen it here and we all get along
I mean I I almost never have to block
someone or delete a comment or anything
I I think it's I think it's amazing
right there's a lot of haters on the
internet and a lot of trolls but they
don't they're not here they're not here
they're good people here you are good
people so I appreciate that and it makes
me want to keep doing this it makes me
want to learn more so that this is
useful for you all
and I can keep doing this so anyway
anyway I'll keep I'm not gonna dwell on
it too much I just I really appreciate
this this community the Andros says hi
I'm from Brazil I love free code camp
awesome awesome
that's cool is that a free code camp is
a huge thing we're doing a lot of stuff
I'm just a very small part of that
Santiago says greetings from Venezuela
awesome thanks for watching mme says in
the field of coding the journey of
knowledge just never ends so true that's
what I love about it
Phoenix says also you know write that
Haley Jones on Twitter will put up for
portfolio tomorrow ok awesome yeah I do
I follow lately Jones on Twitter so
really cool Lauren says thanks for the
answer but scratch is a good way to
begin but is scratch a good way to begin
JavaScript because I do it for 2 years
now I don't really know to yours I'm not
sure if that's years or not but I don't
really know how to go from scratch to
Java I did download grasshopper the new
learn app I haven't had a chance to try
grasshopper yet and I buy grasshopper
that is the new app from Google that
helps you learn JavaScript correct
somebody let me know if I'm wrong on
that I haven't tried it yet like I
mentioned earlier I've just been kind of
in in rush mode here for this website
launch so I haven't done anything on the
side but I'd love to try it I think I've
heard a lot of good things about it
though so I think that may be a good way
to go to get into JavaScript also you go
through the free code camp curriculum so
if you go to
a org and you started on that it'll
start you out with HTML and CSS but then
it'll ease you into JavaScript so that's
a great way to learn as well it's not
the only resource there are a lot of
other resources out there but it's one
that I myself went through
I didn't finish all the free code camp
but I did go through a bit of it and it
definitely helped Lauren says I'm from
Belgium awesome awesome
Nikki's in Belgium too great I love it I
love having people from all over come
Emmys just have to go now happy coding
ACM I may have a great day glad you
could join us
alright and I believe that that's it
that's that's the end of the live chat
so unless someone sneaks another
question in there in the next you know
30 seconds or so I think we're gonna
wrap things up thank you all so much for
watching I know it was a little bit
maybe boring with the data stuff so
hopefully I won't need to do any more
strange with that and I'll get all this
finished soon but anyway like I
mentioned earlier I will try my best to
shrink tomorrow but then the rest of the
week after that I will be at a
conference probably won't be able to
stream and let me know if you're in
Virginia Beach and so maybe we could you
know hang out or something
Wednesday Thursday Friday of this week
I'll be I'll be in Virginia Beach so at
the revolution conference so I guess
I'll see y'all tomorrow
and until then have a great day